bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'un smartphone qui s'appelle le nez
fossé 7 et vous allez voir ce smartphone
est plutôt cool et en plus de ça puisque
je vous l'offre
il se peut que joueur fragile on y va
tout
alors le défaut ces 7 nouveaux produits
de défausse un produit dédié plus pour
le sel fils et marquer ici better selphy
meilleures photos ses marques et la
juste part dans ici et ce smartphone je
vous le faire gagner alors si vous êtes
couler si on a plus de 2 me like très
très très rapidement eh bien on va faire
x 2 au lieu d'en faire gardien on va en
faire gagner deux pareils je sais c'est
presque noël c'est parce que mieux que
noël j'en ai commandé pour vous j'ai
tout réservé pour vous quand on m'a
proposé de tester ce produit j'ai dit oh
que je veux bien mais par contre pour
moi ce qui est important c'est de vous
récompenser et de vous le faire gagner
donc j'ai dit bah écoute et qui peut le
plus peut le moins donc on a doublé les
cadeaux je fais gagner 1 c'est sûr et
certain je vous ai dit tout dans la
description pour participer vous allez
voir c'est très très très facile vous en
fais gagner et pour gagner le deuxième
il faut me mettre des light il faut
light et cette vidéo a more likely
qualité partagée est comme ça le
deuxième sera en jeu et on va doubler
les chances de gagner ce produit alors
concernant cette vidéo c'est qu'on va le
tester
on va l'ouvrir on va regarder un petit
peu ce qu'il a dans le ventre on va
regarder s'il intéresse on va faire ils
me marc better selphy voir si
effectivement les selphy sont de bonne
qualité
on va voir si le rendu est sympa si le
produit correct si le produit est cool
on va l'utiliser
on part tout ça ensemble et puis au
final on fera un petit point global pour
voir si au final se défausser 7 est
intéressant et j'annoncerai les gagnants
directement sur twitter ou sur facebook
donc rester connecté bien évidemment
alors on y va c'est parti pour les tests
donc voilà le produit merci beaucoup à
tp link de m'avoir fait parvenir ses
produits pour pouvoir les tester et les
offrir enfin tester un surtout parce que
le deuxième c'est juste pour le cadeau
et je vous le dis ce n'est les deux me
like le deuxième sera déjà été ouverts
mais que cinq ans mène tout neuf
vous allez vous recevoir et vous allez
pouvoir en profiter et vous allez être
les plus heureux les plus heureux du
monde
allez on y va c'est parti regardez-moi
ça regardez moi ça c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal la boîte est plutôt bien
faite plutôt sexy
on va regarder ça plus en détail tout de
suite déjà un petit tour de la bâtie sur
du propriétaire
ici vous avez tp-link défaut ce qui est
écrit ci la marque
voilà pour moi toutes les infos sur le
modèle l'un peut les références
techniques bon ça on va la gagner tout à
l'heure les caractéristiques techniques
un peu plus en détails pour l'instant on
va directement se concentrer sur cette
jolie boîte et on va l'ouvrir alors bon
je vais y aller plutôt cool parce que ce
produit si on atteint les demies light
au final il ne sera pas à moi il sera à
vous donc on va pas là
on va pas le déchirer alors par où est
souvent est-ce que je peux déjà l'ouvrir
sans risquer de l'abîmer il n'y a pas de
petit coin privilégié des fois on y
aller un peu fort comme ça là à la
regarder à l'amazigh et technique de
vieux routards ça m'évite d'utiliser ce
truc là
alors hop je prends je lourd j'enlève le
plastique se déshabille la mariée comme
on dit chez nous hop voilà merci madame
merci monsieur up peut l'ouvrir avec
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de tendresse
donc ça n'abîme rapaces à loin de moi je
vois ici une petite languette on va le
tirer on va sortir
obama l'a plutôt bien fait et je trouve
quand même j'ai déjà vu un produit de tp
link a essayé un défaut si ya pas très
longtemps si moi je trouve assez grand
pas mal sur la prise en main garder la
taille quand même en élégance produit
pas mal du tout better selphy 13
mégapixels plus 8 mégapixels caméra
alors ici en réalité ans elle fit vous
avez là 8 mégapixels et à l'arrière
vous avez là 13 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.0 là vous avez une
ouverture avec un angle a priori de 80 6
degrés je ne sais pas sur laquelle s'est
on va voir un écran
ultra large 5,5 pouces hd y psc du lcd
1280 par 720 pixels 267 p pays
0,2 seconde pour déverrouiller derrière
je le dis j'ai 6 ans notre modèle
effectivement ça désir ou très très
rapidement on va revoir tout à l'heure
pour un full performance oct accord 64
bits processeur ma foi tout ça ça a
l'air d'être plutôt pas mal
alors c'est un médiathèque un certain mt
6750 il faut savoir dedans vous avez une
batterie de 3060 millions paire eur 2
gigas de ram 16 giga de stockage
extensible jusqu'à 128 giga vous êtes du
bluetooth 4 points 1 1 on a un don ici
en polycarbonate qui a un effet un petit
peu métal que je trouve moi pas mal je
trouve franchement il est bien fait
séduisant lors sur le dessus ici on a
une prise jack et là où tous les autres
le supprime bouton de volume
ici le bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre ici du micro usb haut
parleurs bon je pense qu'un seul
haut-parleur sadio parleur mono à mon
avis sur le côté ici l'emplacement pour
votre nom aussi mais votre carte micro
sd
c'est long à l'ouverture et prend son
temps alors il faut savoir pendant ce
temps que l'on est une surcouche n ait
fui 7.0 et on est sur un android 7.0
nougat ou elle comme ce que la surcouche
allait vraiment très épurée elle est
clair aller simple on va pas non plus
lui demander la lune on va pas chez
quelque chose de complètement dingue
dedans mais je trouve que ça marche
plutôt pas mal filtrer la lumière bleue
ça évite effectivement ou l'amont du
cycle car il faut pas y aller trop fort
je le mets je suis très peu la lumière
bleue je trouve que c'est plutôt pas mal
fichu on le voit là le processeur est
cadencé à 2,1 gigahertz de giga de ram
on a 10 gigas disponibles la mémoire sur
les 16 giga à l'intérieur la résolution
de l'écran ou alors on a quelques kills
info dessus en même temps nous on va
regarder un petit peu du côté de la
photo et de la vidéo que ça ça nous
intéresse pas mal je vous le dis c'est
un produit qui a pas de stabilisation on
va pas chercher de la stabilisation là
dessus on se met on va filmer en 720p là
qu'est ce que j'ai ag du 1080p
ok tu peux filmer en full hd dessus
c'est cool sur le mode photographie le
flash activer/désactiver automatique
le hdr que je peux décider de mettre si
je souhaite le format 4/3 16/9 ou 1 1
le mode beauty faille pour rendre les
choses encore plus
beauty faille donc ça on peut le
paramétrer ici et là je passe sur la
caméra d'or caméras devant bonjour à
tous ces mois commente avez-vous donc
caméras devant le mode beauty faille on
a toujours un peu les mêmes choses l'âge
des airs de disponible bon bah voilà les
choses un petit peu classique ça ça
marche plutôt pas mal
on a des filtres ici qu'on peut venir
chercher mémoire aucune froid chaud fils
damian hockey les files 3 et de l'autre
côté caméra professionnelle panorama
ralenti time lapse si je vais dans le
mode pro régler mais iso je peux régler
la balance des blancs ch peut régler pas
mal de petites choses
ouais c'est pas mal c'est pas mal une
fois n'est pas coutume on va aller faire
un petit tour directement donc là je
filme sur le nez fausse directement sur
la caméra arrière on va aller faire un
petit tour dehors pour regarder ce que
ça dit dans des conditions de bonne
luminosité là je me mets un bon spot
dans la tronche qui me tabassent un peu
donc on va aller voir dehors ce que ça
dit caméra arrière caméra avant à faire
des photos on va regarder ci s'adapte
bien au faible luminosité
au final sur le rendu est cool oui ou
non donc là c'est le printemps chaud à
l'extérieur regarder si elle est au
repos ce qui commence à arriver
c'est sympa c'est beau cette nature au
printemps ça caille encore un peu mais
ça va donc bon je vous dis la
stabilisation sur les caméras hier au
jour là mais je pense que la
stabilisation
c'est pas génial génial néanmoins pas
non plus demander la lune on va regarder
maintenant je vais un film edit
ratissage de filmer les roses l'a résumé
dessus je peux vous mais voilà le vous
c'est vraiment horrible
oh lala com c'est pixelisé nom de dieu
je trouve que par rapport à ce que je
vois moi tout de suite la réalité il ya
un petit peu moins de couleurs un petit
peu moins de tonus mais on respecte
vraiment les teintes et ça pour le coup
c'est pas mal ce sens la caméra de
selphy lapointe coup je vois ma tronche
et je vois effectivement qu'à une fois
de plus stabilisation même où russel ça
fait m j'ai un peu moins de lumière
j'ai des plantes voilà ça fait une jolie
cachette s'adapte plutôt pas mal
ouais c'est un peu un peu saturé là un
peu brillant et sur le dessus là mais
bon il faut de plus à l'est sur un
produit qui n'est pas trop cher la
caméra c'est du 8 mégapixels ça fait la
faire on va rentrer dans une zone un peu
plus sombre pour parce que ça dit suivez
moi je me cogne joe torre voilà
ça marche ça va ça regarde pas trop me
cogner ça s'adapte plutôt pas mal faible
luminosité
ça c'est sombre ici quand même non ça
c'est plutôt bien la faire que ça marche
plutôt pas mal c'était quelques photos
je trouve que c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal hein les rendus sont plutôt bien
ça respecte assez bien la luminosité ça
respecte pas trop mal les couleurs ouais
je trouve que fondamentalement pour
faire des souvenirs faire des choses on
l'a déjà les une tapisserie énormément
mais je trouve que pour faire des petits
souvenirs c'est vraiment bien
il ya rien à dire on va pas cracher dans
la soupe ça fait quand même des rangs du
qui sont vraiment de bonne qualité des
bons souvenirs
après moi ce que je trouve très bien ce
smartphone c'est le déverrouillage et
j'avais déjà remarqué sur le précédent
produit que j'avais testé dès qu'on
appuie un deux trois salles et
verrouille tout de suite le
déverrouillage une petite vibration
c'est très réactif
le capteur est bien fait non vraiment je
trouve que c'est vraiment un truc est
super mais en tout cas voilà je trouve
que le produit pour avoir un smartphone
pas cher d'entrée de gamme je trouve que
ce n'est fausse c'est cette marche
plutôt bien
alors maintenant arrêtez ce cadre est de
la boîte parce qu'on a regardé le
smartphone n'a pas bio l'intérieur ici
vous avez quoi est-ce que nous sommes
une petite coque de protection qu'on
avait déjà dans un ancien modèle non là
y'en a pas là ya pas de coques de
protection là une déclaration pro forma
t on des notices d'utilisation on a une
protection d'écran qui est ici qui est
plutôt pas mal
à l'intérieur le câble de recharge ceux
du plastique
ok vous avez ici up votre câble micro
usb avec un câble usb
ici une triste d'écouteurs ça c'est cool
vole un peu pour cette vidéo sur le nez
face c'est cette noix je le trouve
plutôt cool je trouve séduisant la prise
en main est correct les photos les
vidéos sont bonnes ça roule alors c'est
pas non plus un truc exceptionnel on est
sur un produit d'entrée de gamme des
produits coup quand même moins de 200
euros avec intérêts que vous allez
pouvoir trouver qu'il oscille entre 150
euros à 190 euros
il est fondamentalement pas cher en
produit quand même à moins de 200 euros
qui est comme ça qui fonctionne bien il
est séduisant il est cool dont ça je
trouve pas mal donc plutôt un point
positif pour ce produit pour le défaut
ce c7
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous trouvez
intéressant à ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter vous laisser séduire
en attendant pour tous ceux qui auront
la chance de gagner d'un alignement elle
a déjà un divers
qui vous a tant qu attend que vous donc
y en a deux parmi vous sont atteints les
2000 ait très rapidement qu aura la
chance de partir avec et pour les autres
va falloir aller m'acheter un voilà vous
avez les liens en descriptions merci à
vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je vous
donne rendez vous très très très très
bientôt pour prochaine vidéo des
concours des infos des excuses des news
et vous allez voir je travaille
pleinement sur la rentrée du mois de
septembre
et ça va envoyer du bois croyez moi
d'ici là soigner sa santé vous bien
je vous embrasse et je vous dis à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]